pour parler votre accident de voiture
vous l'avez longtemps cachés sur des
réseaux sociaux ce qui fait que votre
visage était un petit peu déformé les
gens étaient très très très méchant avec
vous pour être honnête vous avez reçu à
tpm paix dans tpm paix j'étais assis en
face et même moi je m'étais dit qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait comme chirurgie et
tout ça j'ai fait partie des connards
entre guillemets je dois l'avouer je ne
savais pas donc regarder et puis on va
parler juste après triple fracture de la
mâchoire perte de la sensibilité du
visage dentition cassé marie est
défigurée cette beauté dont elle est si
fière n'existe plus et plus
et puis alors quand j'entendais les
soignants qui venaient me parler qu'ils
aient non mais arrêtez relativiser vous
êtes toujours vivante
mais j'aurais préféré être morte ans
morte belle que 10 ans témoin ça c'est
touchant quand même c'était un reportage
très touchant et hier que vous avez
regardez aujourd'hui comment vous vous
sentez il me sens mieux mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut vivre avec ce visage que je
n'accepte pas c'est pas très déformée
mariko pour la plupart des gens ne le
voient pas mais moi au quotidien dans le
miroir je le vois et on a tendance à
focaliser en fait quand il ya quelque
chose de différent sur soi qu'on accepte
pas on a tendance à focaliser dessus
et pour le coup c'est le cas pour mon
visage pour mes cicatrices et il reste
des choses à que vous voulez encore
changé et modifié
ben c'est pas totalement terminée au
niveau de mon visage en fait j'ai
notamment la dentition j'attends dans la
cicatrisation pour pouvoir avoir des
dents correct que tout est visiblement
enfin visuellement ça va nickel mais
c'est vrai que dessous tout est cassé
mais quand tu eu d'accident pour ne pas
en avoir parlé vous avez dit que vous
avez été massacrés sur les réseaux
sociaux et des tweets horrible t la
nouvelle bogdanov
c'est pourquoi parce que sam
appartenaient en fait c'est le genre
d'événement qu'on n'a pas envie de
partager avec qui que ce soit quand on
est connu entre guillemets on partage ce
qu'on avait envie de partager on dit sa
vie ce qu'on a envie de dire qui pour le
coup ça m'appartenait j'avais envie de
le vivre seul et de me reconstruire seul
j'avais pas besoin que ce soit mis sur
le devant de la scène
pourquoi vous dites les gens me prennent
pour une fille sans cervelle une
pourriture je suis la fille la plus
détestée de toute la télé réalité c'est
le sentiment vous avez ou quoi oui oui
oui parce que je suis constamment
insulté mais c'est de tous ces va
rejeter suicide toi tu sers à rien c'est
une honte qu'une fille comme toi sont
infirmières n'a honte pour la
représentation de notre métier la honte
pour mes pour regretter d'avoir fait la
cicad story et puis les anges ensuite de
revel la télé réalité
non je regrette pas du tout parce que
c'est que ça devait arriver tout arrive
pour de bonnes raisons dans la vie à
part mes croyances notamment je pense
rien pourtant c'est un peu à cause 2 6
bat pas l'accident mais si vous êtes
détester si vous avez autant souffert si
vous vous êtes séparé de votre copain
derrière vous dites par exemple peu
importe la somme d'argent comme vous
proposerai même une fortune j'ai mis
trop longtemps à me débarrasser la
télé-réalité c'est fini quand on parle
de ça comme ça quand même c'est que il
ya un très bon souvenir
c'est un bon souvenir mais
malgré tout ça m'a apporté beaucoup de
choses dans le sens où ça m'a fait mûrir
voilà ça m'a fait grandir je me suis
vraiment renforcé et j'aborde la vie de
façon tout à fait différente ça m'a
rendu aussi plus humble pie x la semaine
dernière il ya une une candidate de
secret story qui a dit mama le contrat
de discrétion va dire est passé
maintenant je peux parler raconter à
quel point c'était truqué à quel point
il ya on nous laissait dans la nuit on
nous affamer des cigarettes étaient au
compte gouttes les secrets parfois où
nous les donner pour être sûr de pouvoir
en avoir et tout ça est ce que tout ça
vous l'avez vécu est ce que oui
effectivement secretstory aujourd'hui ça
fait dix ans vous pouvez pas en parler
est-ce que secretstory en effet c'était
à ce point truc et je vais pas cracher
dans la soupe parce que bon moi j'ai
gagné
si je dis que c'est truqué voudrait dire
qu'on a arrangé un à victoire et je le
pense sincèrement pas mais après c'est
vrai que on avait une demi-heure d'eau
chaude par jour ouais on avait une
demi-heure de ses cheveux par jour qu'on
nous déréglé leur que la maison était
dégueulasse et ça ça c'est vrai qu'on
vous affamez un peu qu'on essaie de nous
affamer les cigarettes et au congo
d'ascq avait de l'alcool il n'y avait
pas en avait un
un verre de mousseux par soir après l'or
à tel point que au bout d'un mois et
dont geico avait donné son vert à
aurélie et geoffrey m'avait donné son
vert d'accord et sur l'herbe avec
aurélie dans la fosse est en retrait de
se faire des déclarations d'amour
compose pour supporter plus du tout très
bien mais rien vous avez une question
mais en fait
est-ce que vous attendent en tout c'est
vrai que dans toutes les émissions de
télé réalité vous avez fait vous aviez
quand même une image pas très
sympathique parce que vous étiez tout le
temps la pleureuse
tout le monde vous détestez déjà dans
l'émission est-ce que ça aussi ça
certainement jouer aussi sur l'image que
les autres on est pourquoi en fait vous
pleuriez autant dans toutes les énigmes
que ce soit secretstory les anges quand
vous étiez un peu là là là d'habitude
tout le temps là rien à voir déjà il
faut savoir qu'on nous montre 45 minutes
de 24 heures déjà on montre un petit peu
ce qu'on veut et moi j'étais en couple
dans cette émission
mais même dans les engins les disputes y
en aa pas à ce que des mésanges en a
voulu pour dire la vérité repasser la
jfp que vous avez donnée à geoffrey les
images maintenant sont interdites on
peut plus dépasser mais c'est vrai que
vous étiez violente à cette époque là
vous pensez que c'est la télé à l'été
qui vous a rendu comme ça
non je pense pas que ce soit la télé
réalité c'est juste qu'en fait je
trouvais tellement les choses injustes
et j'étais là pour me battre pour mon
couple clairement ça me rendait
complètement ouf
oui complètement folle de voir à quel
point les gens s'acharner sur notre
couple et avait envie de nous détruire
et de voir à quel point mon mec
finalement on n'avait rien à faire dans
le dogme vous dites je rends compte que
des tocards que des gens qui pensent que
je suis j'ai plein de fric et que du
coup je suis la fille de la télé réalité
donc je ne peux jamais être en couple
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous l'êtes mon
coeur est pris non ça ne serait pas plus
on peut vouloir dire beaucoup de choses
ça va éveiller plein de fantasmes donc
ça peut vouloir dire beaucoup de choses
comme très peu de chances que son coeur
est pris juste à lui aussi c'est
toujours chiant à ses côtés j'ai
l'impasse sur les noms et tout ça je
dirai pas plus parce que lui mais d'un
coup de coeur aussi répète ça veut dire
prises pour moi mais bon elle alors à
l'autisme du seuil
il va être devant chez vous maintenant
penser à ces bons à la photo c'est clair
donc la photo à partir mathieu une
question et magazines à moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que vous expliquer en
gros finalement vous étiez content sonné
à un rôle finalement et quand on voit
vous êtes un rôle de méchant quand on
appuie ont fait super méchant ça me
chante un nom mais est en fait j'ai
l'impression que dans télé réalité le
mot le plus important c'était les
finalement l'arrivée elle a oublié sa
marie je pense dans toutes les émissions
que tu as fait tu t'es tu t'es dévoilé
et a été trop haute à montrer tes
faiblesses et je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut pas faire il faut pas oublier
que c'est de la télé en oui mais
réaliste il faut pas faire et c'est
comme ça qu'on gagne aussi parce que
c'était comme ça que loana a gagné ses
copains on doit gagner vos applis qui
sans ça il sent que les gens sont vraies
ce que ça existe beaucoup aussi mais là
je reconnais que parfois les people sont
un petit peu dans le coup aussi des
fausses paparazzades mari on peut en
parler aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'à l'époque vous faisiez des
boîtes de nuit on gagne beaucoup
d'argent ce qu est ce que vous avez déjà
fait des fausses paparazzades c'est à
dire en accord avec des magazines bas
des fausses photos pour gagner de
l'argent
oui lesquelles par exemple c'est qu'il a
oui avec gekko le candidat de secret
story je sais plus lequel vous avez
récemment de sortir ensemble
oui donc voilà c'est des sorties dans un
magazine qu'elle a non je ne sais plus
je suis un magazine un magazine c'est un
problème c'était quoi les montants on
était à 30 milles on était chez moi on
s'affronte secret' euros pour chacun non
non à 2,15
nous sommes arrivés à fait secret story
mais à ce prix là moi j'ai fait un petit
bout je suis indépendant mais mary mary
était a été une des stars de latéralité
qui était la plus chère à huy a été le
cac a le mieux marché qu'elle lui ait
fait de cook a fait le plus de
couverture c'était le temps de secret
story qui cartonnait sur tf1 mais
vraiment une grosse audience
elle était très très populaire très on a
fait beaucoup de couverture de closer
avec les interviews elle raconté les
problèmes et que geoffrey tout ce qu'on
veut faire elle a beaucoup donné
d'interview il a eu du coup forcément ça
crée sa pas être naïf et très souvent
aussi les hésitations les crises
arrivent d'aujourd'hui ont déjà la télé
réalité fait beaucoup moins d'audience
du oui alors on fait plus de
photographier les gens pour des consoles
à elle une question juste honnête à
hamar ici on et voilà si tu mets
boutabout les 190 mille euros de 6,4
story toutes ses photos ses fausses
paparazzades plus des photos un peu
officiel plus les booking quand on perd
on va faire des sites des signatures ou
dans des boîtes de nuit tu estimes de la
télé réalité tu as gagné quoi qu'avec
les anges aussi peut-être cinq cent
mille euros
non non non non plus tandis que j'ai
fait très peu de booking d'accord donc
dans les boîtes de nuit
justin koua 400000 euros non non je
dirais que j'ai gagné un voyage de 150
1258 ok très bien oui mais rien ne va
pas dans sébastien sébastien oui
inscrire beaucoup de fausses
paparazzades parfois je suis vraiment
totalement contre les fausses
paparazzades avec les gens de télé
réalité parce que si heureusement ils en
font plus ça a été le cas un moment ça
empiétait sur les vrais paparazzade
et c'est vraiment prendre les lecteurs
pour des comptes la banque liste d'amis
y en a il y en a eu à une époque où
beaucoup non mais c'est pas bien
heureusement c'est passer de moi mais je
dirais qu'il ya dix ans il y avait que
ça parce que c'était simple n'y avait
pas de procès ça faisait vendre ça
marchait c'est énorme et c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est à dire qu'on
faisait d'aider des sujets les voilà on
voulait sortir des scoops pour pouvait
c'était des gens accessibles donc on les
appelait mais les sujets n'étaient pas
des faux truc c'est qu'il faut que c'est
l'image qu'on donne un mejia demandé
faussement ne ment pas j'étais à nrj 12
les connaît tous par coeur
linkin une marche ce ne sera pas son nom
qui me dit tiens je pose parce que j'ai
fait une fausse couche mais tu étais
enceinte non la copine et tennisman je
suis pas non je vais bientôt images de
victimes en fait je pense que c'est ce
qu'a aussi un peu agacé les gens vous
êtes mais en soi quand vous dites que ça
vous a gêné et que vous dites là on télé
que
vous préférez être morte que moche alors
comme moi par exemple j'ai un candidat
l'été dernier qui est décédé lui ses
parents je veux dire j'ai accompagné
c'est terrible ce que vous dites que je
pense que ses parents auraient préféré
l'avoir moche que mort s que vous pouvez
comprendre aussi l'agacement des gens de
vous entendre dire des choses comme ça
des fois oui je peux comprendre
exactement je peux comprendre mais là
par rapport à cette sas comment
d'actionnement ça me choque ce que vous
venez de mais il faut il faut le vivre
aussi
oui mais en fait vous n'avez pas de
passer ses résidents bien sûr vous
voulez des changes environ av titre
s'est dit prêt à nommer est-ce que vous
avez vu dans un miroir où vous trouve
très jolie et je pense que il ya des
gens qui magali magail
la première à avoir des 10900 faire
attention c'est conforme à ce que match
ça n'a rien à voir la chirurgie
esthétique mais celle là même si chacun
dit les choses comme il le peut chamarré
j'aimerais juste qu enfin qu'on commence
juste dans un monde où et surtout le
monde de la télé réalité ou si on est
moche on n'est pas heureux alors que
iron man ne t'a pas d'émettre un plateau
comme daniel